Oh
welcome to episode 3 of BuzzFeed's
running out of ideas yes it's still the
same day what we've done is took popular
keywords and put them on some dice then
we roll those dice whatever combination
of words it lands on is the title of our
video so let's get to it
for a third time okay so I'm here with
the team we're ready to roll the dice
and find ourselves a video go there you
go yeah terrifying terrifying lip makeup
DIY yeah so I feel like we can't just do
a hundred levels because it's overdone
now I have an idea why don't we just put
lipstick everywhere out of course I feel
like there's a different route we can go
other than just painting whole fake
flesh lips what this looks like you have
no but I like that idea nicely yeah like
be DIY flesh lips looks like it's just
there's no lips there yeah fleshless
great
[Music]
well the day has come it is time for
terrifying DIY lip makeup so I'm here
with Emily and we are going to make it
look like I have no lips again you're
fine with just breathing out of your
nose right sure right I'm gonna look
like a Simpson I'm gonna have to stop
talking soon our night oh yeah I'm just
gonna pull put on like modeling wax now
like I can't laugh either yeah
just keep molding it until I get like
this smooth surface
[Music]
[Music]
that looks so weird now that I'm looking
at it I'm kind of like oh maybe this was
a no lip surprise talking all right
let's bring her around she's get your
[Music]
Jordan always the one that's
interpreting everything
good great wrote it on time
whoa whoa whoa it's kind of scary sorry
I can't look I don't trust her oh I
really want to be done with this now so
really taking off okay well terrifying
DIY lip makeup it's a video
you know ii you can't have something you
want it ii I couldn't talk I just like
had all these things to say